donc le front national était présent
dans à peu près tous les cantons sur les
trois départements
au vu des résultats de ce soir qu'est ce
que vous que dites vous c'est un
résultat qui vous saisissait oui alors
la première chose bien entendu on va
remercier tous les électeurs qui nous
ont fait confiance et qui ont pu
manifester une adhésion à un programme
parce que c'est pas simplement une
contestation sur les autres partis mais
je crois que maintenant les gens ils se
rendent compte que effectivement le
front national propose un programme
différent à l'ump ps et tous leurs
consorts poisson pilote
donc à partir de là effectivement on est
quand même très satisfait parce que on a
pratiquement presque doubler si vous
voulez les résultats de 2011
on faisait 15 % là on arrive autour de
25% des fois voire plus un peu moins
donc effectivement c'est une très très
belle percée qui signifie que les gens
adhèrent à notre programme peut-on
parler d'implantation alors justement le
saas et le but c'est une implantation
alors après le second tour va nous dire
ah qu'est ce qu'on a comme élu bien
entendu on peut pas non plus le trop se
projeter
mais ce qui est important c'est
l'implantation ce pouvoir donner d'une
capacité aux électeurs front national
d'avoir des candidats à chaque élection
de façon d'une certaine façon qu'ils se
sentent pas isolés et qui à partir de là
c'est le début de l'implantation sur les
territoires est ce que des élections
locales c'est avant tout des gens qui
sont implantés durablement sur un
secteur
ce sera le cas c'est des gens qui vont
continuer à travailler avec bien entendu
le but c'est ça c'est de former des
cadres des piles et des gens des
candidats qui veulent s'impliquer qui
s'impliquent
d'ailleurs bon effectivement on a
couvert quand même territoire national
95% des cantons donc il ya vraiment une
dynamique qui est là où les gens
adhèrent à des radars adhère pas ce
qu'il se rende compte
les solutions politiques on nous propose
depuis 10 30 ans voire plus sont
inefficaces et on va à l'échec quoi donc
là il ya une conviction certaine des
candidats et surtout des électeurs qui
soutiennent nos candidats on a beaucoup
entendu l'expression sursaut républicain
ce soit parmi les alors les autres vos
concurrents est ce que ça représentait
un barrage alors ça ça c'est ça qui me
fait un peu sourire
là on est en plein bébête show séoul et
qu'on a connu encore le pendant les
dernières élections vous savez la
tactique pour faire une vérité c'est de
répéter un mensonge
voilà c'est qu elles font républicain
quelles sont leurs valeurs républicaines
qui nous disent moi j'observe que si un
parti qui est bien républicain c'est le
front national
et pour cause qui a trahi le peuple avec
le traité de lisbonne en 2005 alors que
le peuple a dit non au traité de
lisbonne sur schengen et il était passé
l'assemblée nationale par le mps et
consorts poissons pilotes et tout ce
qu'on veut c'est quand même c'est parti
là qu'ils abandonnent la souveraineté du
peuple qui fait partie de la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et de démocratie
la bande à bruxelles c'est quand même
l'ump est ce qui fait la mode de scrutin
qui est tout à fait anti démocratique si
vous voulez on observe aux dernières
élections présidentielles on avait fait
je crois 18 % d'électeurs et on a juste
des députés
les écologistes font 2 % de voix ils ont
18 députés et après salut mps nous dit
que c'est ce le front républicain
mais c'est quand même c'est bon se
moquer du monde dernière question de
nombreux binôme du front national seront
présents au second tour pour ce que vous
avez combien d'électeurs raisonnablement
non honnêtement réponse
on n'est pas dans ce cas de figure on ne
s'est pas amusé à faire ses calculs
on avait vraiment un souci de développer
un programme c'est d'ailleurs à ce
niveau là je permettrai je ferai
remarquer c'est quand même curieux que
ces deux partis ump s et consorts
veulent la disparition département et se
bousculent pour être élu conseiller
départemental il ya quand même un sacré
paradoxe si vraiment il ya un parti
politique en l'occurrence le front
national c'est le seul qui veut vraiment
défendre la commune et le département
qui sont quand même une richesse et une
sécurité de proximité pour les
administrés mais vous croyez avoir
deux élus ou plus peut-être savez il
second tour sur des fois un petit peu
comment je dire un peu riche en
découvertes
allez donc savoir ce que les électeurs
vont faire bon voilà quoi c'est non je
ne fais pas trop de pronostic à ce
niveau là effectivement on aimerait bien
avoir le plus grand nombre d'élus si on
peut en avoir deux trois quatre ou cinq
sérieux voilà au même titre que là on
aurait été en fait encore un meilleur
score on serait encore plus ravi si vous
voulez c'est bien entendu mais on est
très confiants et raisonnable si vous
voulez dans la dina dynamique qu'on a su
créer l'adhésion qu'on a parce que là
c'est une adhésion à notre programme va
à travers si vous voulez le peuple au
sens du terme et donc on sait très bien
que ça un train qui roule à chaque
élection on monte on monte on monte on
monte et c'est cette dynamique là qui
vraiment nous fait plaisir quoi